[Musique]
entretiens politiques avec julien son
beau mr de huy bonjour monsieur le maire
bonjour alors quelques mots sur votre
vie qui situe à l'extrême est des
yvelines des kits très proche de paris
très proche aussi de saint germain en
laye elle est dans les yvelines mais
elle est très proche des hauts de seine
et du val d'oise
c'est une vie de très dense très
construite vous même pendant la campagne
électorale vous avez parlé de la
bétonisation de cette ville qui compte
environ 35000 habitants et une
population relativement jeune
alors vous avez été élu au deuxième tour
des élections municipales face au maire
sortant alexandre joly qui dirigeait
cette commune depuis 25 ans d'abord
est-ce que ça a été ça a été une
surprise est ce que vous pensez que
c'était une une bastille imprenable ça a
été une surprise
non parce qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
travail et travail collectif pour
présenter ce projet municipal aux
neuvillois donc née en moi ça quand même
été une heureuse surprise de sens - en
effet traditionnellement quand une ville
est tenue par un maire en place depuis
de nombreuses années on sait que c'est
toujours plus délicate arrivé de façon
complètement extérieur est ce qu'il faut
rappeler que je n'étais pas élu au
valable donc en ça ça a été je vais dire
en tout cas après un renouvellement de
l'offre politique aubinoise ça c'est sûr
qu'est ce qui vous a poussé vous à
vouloir devenir maire de cette ville est
d'ailleurs quels sont vos souvenirs avec
avec oui je pense qu'on veut vraiment
devenir le 28e ville déjà fait beaucoup
l'aimé beaucoup aimé sa ville y est
rattachée donc moi je suis réveillé
maintenant plus de dix ans plus de dix
ans et mes enfants fait ils sont nés
donc ça veut dire que j'ai un
attachement qui se construit que ce soit
avec eux avec les parents avec
l'activité avec la ville c'est un
territoire dans lequel on a envie
finalement aussi de bach la fine de les
deux enfants se construisent en harmonie
donc je pense le premier tenir il est là
après le deuxième lien c'est aussi la
vie locale la pièce fiat yves les gens
rencontrent font que yara
je pense très fort à cette ville qui
s'est réalisé et ça donne en fait la
volonté le carburant finalement pour
devenir avoir la prétention en tout cas
de se présenter devant les audi loi et
construire un projet pour une ville ce
qui prend beaucoup d'énergie donc le car
blanc c'était ça l'attachement à la
ville profond le milieu associatif
le fait que les enfants ils soient d ça
m'a vraiment enraciné
ah oui vous même vous êtes chef d'une
entreprises du numérique vous êtes aussi
sociologue de formation
est ce que ces deux voies la santé c'est
dont vous vous ont préparé à la fonction
de maire
je pense qu'en tout cas ma formation
universitaire de sociologues m'a
vraiment appris en tout cas à analyser
les situations et être très attentif au
fonctionnement en tout cas de voilà deux
de la société des différentes relations
humaines et des groupes en tout cas ça
sera ma donné cette appétence pour la
compréhension de l'organisation sociale
ça c'est la première chose c'est un peu
mon socle et même dans ma façon d'être
dans le dans le projet politique que je
mène
et toujours ce souci là de bien
comprendre les mécanismes ne pas arriver
un peu sabre au clair mais au contraire
de comprendre aussi que le politique
il est aussi dépendant de la société
dans laquelle il évolue et qu'on doit
qu'au petit comprendre des situations
complexes que vous n'est jamais à la
place des autres
complètement mais il faut apprendre un
peu à se mettre aussi à la place des
autres ça je vais dire c'est un peu la
port on va dire intellectuelle que la
sociologie va donner quand on fait de la
politique on est la clé 3g pour les
autres autant comprendre aussi un petit
peu leur façon de penser
c'est un peu la base après sur l'aspect
digital c'est vrai que ça va vous donner
beaucoup d'appétence sur la
transformation de notre société sur la
façon dont le modèle économique évolue
dont l'organisation sociale évolue on le
voit à quel point le confinement et la
pandémie nous a obligés aussi d'ailleurs
a accéléré des processus digitalisation
font survivre
donc ça c'est vrai que sur l'action
publique la construction d'une politique
publique la relation de l'habitant à sa
ville de du citoyen à sa démocratie le
cas de l'usager à ce service public
l'aspect digital m'a donné beaucoup
d'éléments comprendre pour construire
différemment pour repenser les choses on
mettre à plat des éléments est tout
simplement pour construire une société
une ville
moderne qui vit dans son temps qui n'a
pas trop le choix mais qui doit
l'accompagner se l'approprier faire sa
proposition
là vous êtes membre de la république en
marche ne peut pas dire que les
municipales étaient très favorables à
votre mouvement mais est ce que ça coûte
au fond l'appartenance politique dans
une élection municipale ou est-ce que ce
fait un petit peu différent des autres
scrutins
je pense que ça compte pas vous la
vérité
je pense que ce qui compte vraiment les
gens sont pas dupes c'est de savoir
qu'est ce qui va être fait pour leur
ville
qu'est ce que est ce qu'on a bien
compris le problème de leur vie
quotidienne ou tout simplement les
problèmes les dysfonctionnements qui
sont constatés et quelle est la
proposition en face on fait de ringer
d'originalité de sérieux quand je pense
que c'est ça qui compte
moi aujourd'hui ma boussole c'est ma
ville c'est mon territoire alors après
ça que l'éthique et lrm elle permet
quand même de donner à voir un
positionnement on va dire de valeur en
gros progressistes pour vous positionner
sur l'échiquier politique
mais c'est une finalement et un spectre
politique est assez large
donc en tout cas voilà ça envoie ce
signal là mais ça ne fait pas du tout la
nature d'une élection la nature du vote
des aux lillois au niveau local comme
dans n'importe quelle ville est beaucoup
plus complexe ou plus rattachées à des
enjeux locaux
la majeure partie des décès pas une
aventure solitaire municipalité s'est au
contraire celui d' équipe c'est tout un
conseil municipal s'est beaucoup de
villes qui se sont engagés avec moi et
pour la majeure partie l'écrasante
majorité d'entre eux l'engagement
politique ne fait pas sens pour cet
enjeu municipal au contraire ce sont des
gens qui étaient dans l'appli
associative qui sont très variées
parfois politiquement ce qui nous
rassemble c'est vraiment cette vision
pour notre ville
les valeurs dans notre ville et notre
engagement local ces sacs éventrés
structurants qui fait aussi la clé de
compréhension et le la victoire le cas
d'échec politique aussi dans une huile
alors vous avez parlé je disais tout à
l'heure de bétonisation de la ville
et puis le maire sortant vous a dit oui
mais avant il a fallu construire des
logements sociaux et puis il ya une
nouvelle population qui est arrivé donc
il fallait bien faire face à ces ces
deux contraintes
vous pensez que on pouvait faire
autrement et qu'on peut faire autrement
on doit faire autrement on doit faire
autrement parce qu'on a une ville qui a
une forte identité peu moins dire déjà
de propriétaires occupants
ça c'est important ça donne un peu le la
nature de les gens font moins d'efforts
ils investissent ah oui ça coûte cher
donc il faut que l'on préserve cet
esprit là ce rapport à l'habitat et ce
rapport à la ville et puis on a eu un
paysage urbain pavillonnaire auquel on
tient maintenant il faut pas être
démagogique
donc on a fêté rappelez vous les 20 ans
de la loi sru hier dimanche je sais pas
si vous avez sorti votre petite flûte de
champagne mais croyez moi dans ce moment
c'est plutôt compliqué pour les maires
notamment de notre territoire je parle
aussi en tant que vice président de
l'agglomération à l'habitat et au
logement
on voit bien que c'est un vrai défi pour
nos villes qui sont déjà très dense où
l'avait dit en introduction c'est la
ville la plus dense des yvelines oui et
dont surtout le l'intégralité du
territoire et bat ok c'est vrai et ça
c'est important de le dire que cette loi
sur les logements sociaux et bien nous
est une forte contrainte
maintenant il faut qu'on soit plus
intelligent il faut qu'on projette la
ville sur les prochaines années comment
est ce que on modernise la ville comment
est ce qu'on la retrouve l comment
est-ce qu'on permet aussi à nos jeunes
dans une ville dont les prix au mètre
carré au loyer augmente très fortement
comment est-ce que cette contrainte là
on l'intègre dans notre façon projeter
l'avenir de la ville de façon
intelligente apaisé mesure est donc ça
veut dire que en effet au niveau de mon
prédécesseur c'était compliqué parce que
la loi sru à leurs attentes donc ça veut
dire quand même que pendant quelques
années et rien n'a été fait on se
retrouve plus on arrive à un objectif
qui sont les 25 ans de la loi qui vont
arriver là en 2025
très clairement ça s'accélère on ne peut
pas absorber cette accélération
facilement ça c'est évident qu'il faut
que en refaisant l'occurrence j'ai
relancé la révision du pmu on intègre
cette salle cela dans la vision on
détermine en concertation avec les
habitants là où on n'acceptera d'avoir
une plus forte densité
là on doit absolument préserver notre
tissu pavillonnaire parce qu'il est
d'équilibrer pas s'il est harmonieux et
c'est comme ça on va progressivement
finalement gérer cette contrainte là en
bonne intelligence dans l'intérêt de la
ville et des hobbies loi c'est ça qu'il
faut réussir à faire utiliser avant une
vision pour notre ville ou une
contrainte devient à part à m il faut
qu'on gère intelligemment alors deux
questions rapides parce qu'il nous reste
plus beaucoup de temps
il ya un point sur lequel vous avez
beaucoup insisté c'est la sécurité est
ce que vous êtes d'accord vous avez des
collègues des confrères notamment sage
amant les emplois cie qui demande que
les maires et plus de responsabilité de
deux dans le pouvoir enfin dans le
domaine de la sécurité est ce que vous
désapprouvez alors oui ah oui on va être
très volontariste sur la politique de
sécurité locales on a dix ans de retard
il faut pour construire une véritable
police municipale on n'a pas le choix
c'est une attente forte des habitants
et c'est aussi le fruit d'une
réorganisation structurelle assez forte
des services de l'état infogrames pas se
voiler la face
la police nationale a de moins en moins
de moyens notamment pour se déployer sur
le terrain bon en fait les collectives
n'ont pas trop le choix
après attention il faut le faire en
bonne intelligence key
d'irresponsabilité dix obligations 10
moyens il faut aussi avoir les moyens de
cette ambition on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui dans une ville comme ou y
avoir tout budget de fonctionnement qui
pourraient être consacrées à voir
beaucoup trop d'effectifs pour ça il
faut être très prudent et surtout il
faut le faire en bonne intelligence avec
la police nationale qui malgré tout fait
un travail remarquable sur notre
territoire je souligne la bonne
intelligence et la bonne coopération
avec le commissaire de la
circonscription
donc là il faut qu'on avance voilà sûr
on construisit politiques publiques
locales de sécurité
en coordination avec la police nationale
mais oui à wil comme dans beaucoup de
villes on va monter en puissance ces
demandes des habitants
et c'est finalement une obligation face
aux pertes de moyens de la police
nationale a très rapidement parce qu'on
a dépassé de tanguiéta parti mais comme
je voulais vous poser la question vous
avez dit je veux pas que où ils
deviennent une ville de la petite
couronne
ça veut dire quoi et ça implique
quelle décision ça veut dire que oui
aujourd'hui c'est une belle endormie une
belle endormie une ville de grande
banlieue dont on veut qu'elle se
réveille un petit peu pour trouver
qu'elle a à faire mal au coeur de ville
les plus beaux marchés l'île de france
on a un des tissus associatif les plus
importants on a aussi un nombre de
licenciés sportifs extraordinaire on a
de nombreux atouts pour que cette ville
est ultime elle même sa propre vie sa
solidarité qu'elle soit une polarité
donc ça c'est important maintenant on
voit bien on est soumis à une volonté de
transformation de modernisation de
renouvellement mais il faut qu'on
réinvente la ville on parle beaucoup de
transition écologique mais ça passera
par l'habitat ça passera par le bâtiment
il faut qu'on repense la ville différent
on apporte plus de nature aussi en ville
on traite l'immeuble avec une cinquième
façade
il faut qu'on montre auzeville aux
habitants que c'est pas parce que la
ville se transforme que c'est au
détriment du cadre de vie
donc c'est pour ça que aujourd'hui la
petite couronne s'est construite en sur
le modèle parisien haussmannien très
minéral très dense il faut qu'on accepte
transformer la ville mais à l'aune des
nouveaux enjeux de société transition
écologique solidarité santé cadre de vie
c'est exactement ça qu'on doit faire
dans cette seule responsabilité et bien
c'est un beau programme
on aura l'occasion d'en reparler très
très très certainement merci beaucoup
julien chambon et à très vite voilà on
pour reparler de votre ville de mouiller
merci à vous pour votre invitation et à
très bientôt
[Musique]